et les bons soirs dit ronald l'actualité
internationale du jeu d'échecs ce soir
avec et lorlanges aux sorelois
bonsoir stephen bonsoir à tous amis
internautes et nous recevant quelqu'un
qui est déjà venu plusieurs fois dans
l'émission c'est nicolas la vallée
bonsoir stephen bonsoir et loir nicolas
veille je rappelle donc jour
international et webmaster de la tour
infernale de tout à fait un tour alterne
alors diabolique plus infernal que
jamais je crois que c'est un site qui
grandit de
de plus en plus de visiteurs bon c'est
vrai qu'en ce moment on fait pas mal de
choses notamment des tournois par email
avec la participation d'ailleurs des
lois qui les a fait l'honneur de
participer donc à ces tournois
et puis c'est vrai qu'on prend un petit
peu de poids au fil du temps où ça
devient très sympa maintenant on va
passer tout de suite à l'événement de la
semaine et le grand tournoi de dortmund
voilà donc le terrain de dortmund tout
de suite et loi donc reportage cette
fois avec jean-luc chavanon donc on
dirait que là-bas à dortmund avec donc
tous les joueurs les meilleurs joueurs
du monde
oui j'en accepte donc et donc nouvelle
star de l'interview puisque il a du peps
il est jeune les brillants j'ai fait des
traîtres ils posent des très très bonne
question et prépare très bien ses
interviews donc ce soir du très très bon
matériel puisque nous avons rattrapé
huit joueurs sur 10 ce qui n'est quand
même pas la moindre des choses et nous
avons réussi à interviewer junior le
programme le logiciel d'échec nous qui
est la particularité de se soumettre
dortmund alors peut-être quand même ce
que tout le monde attend je pense que
c'est le placement ce tournoi allons
commencer par commenter le classement
alors rapidement le classement du
tournoi donc sans surprise on peut dire
ouais sans surprise les deux les numéros
2 et 3 mondiaux ont gagné donc surprise
kasparov n'est pas là mais il n'avait
pas joué le tournoi donc sonné ce n'est
plus une surprise dans les rires car
l'équipe est riche manhattan en premier
avec six points sur neuf donc très belle
prestation très belle prestation de ces
deux très fortes lula alors en position
3 on retrouve l'écho adams ya copiant
égalité de points oui alors évidemment
ce qu'il faut voir c'est akopian ici
qu'il arrive à s'illustrer donc au
niveau des joueurs donc qu'ils sont qui
font le paquet des poursuivants de garry
kasparov c'est-à-dire crâne ricanements
de l'écho et adams les quatre joueurs
qui poussent derrière kasparov et ici on
trouve vladmir akopian le vice-champion
du monde de la fidh et qui s'illustre
pas mal puisqu'il score sans point ni
sur neuf c'est à dire plus de ces moi
c'est pas moi c'est un bon score
nicollin c'est pas mal je reviendrai
après sur un petit commentaire sur les
les pronostics 1 termine au classement
et un espoir donc derrière on va
retrouver dix juniors qui fait une
prestation moyenne finalement m'est donc
il a et les joueurs ont démontré qu'ils
n'étaient pas un programme bataille
alors une prestation moyenne entre
guillemets puisque dix juniors
si on peut lui donner un âge il a idéal
à 3 ans donc il essaie tant il est
encore tout jeune il est en automne il
est pratiquement en gestation
et encore en gestation donc à trois ans
c'est déjà pas mal d'arrivées à se
classer donc à 50% dans un tournoi aussi
relevé que ce temps à dortmund qui fait
quand même partie des meilleurs tournois
mondiaux alors ce qu'il faut retenir
quand même je veux insister là dessus à
chaque fois qu'on a un ordinateur ce qui
est important c'est de voir s'il peut
perdre en fait est bon là visiblement il
peut perdre il a perdu deux parties et
deux partis clairement perdu d'ailleurs
sur sur des positions où il n'a pas
compris ce qui se passait oui mais
c'était qu'on aura une seule fois le
plaisir de voir que l'ordinateur ne peut
plus perdre c'est quand il veut pas voir
plus loin c'est vrai donc à 120 dons
pour ne plus se poser la question après
le tournoi est tout à fait dommage mais
pour l'instant d'après les analyses des
joueurs et de lynette gould bichon a
reçus dans diagonale pour des missions
spéciales ordinateur il faudra encore
attendre 25 ans pour que la machine
puisse calculer tant que les
possibilités du jeu d'échecs et donc
devenir imbattable
enfin moi j'aimerais quand même souligné
le joueur qui m'a le plus impressionné
dans ce tournoi c'est toi et loi parce
que je t'avais demandé juste avant que
commence le tournoi un classement et tu
m'avais sortie en un crâne nique en deux
langues en 3 tu es sorti l'écho et
ensuite à dun et c'est quasiment sa wii
alors effectivement c'était pas
forcément très dur de mettre les 4 plus
fort aux quatre premières places mais
mais bon c'est il me semble que je les
avais dans le bon ordre donc c'était pas
mal c'était pas mal mais suit on
retrouvera donc à égalité kalichman et
barrières qui font tourner un petit peu
de mitaines kalichman décidément ils
n'arrivent pas à se dessiner quand même
au niveau des tous meilleurs coins oui
alors qu'ali fans peut-être qu'il est en
train de se préparer pour remettre son
titre en jeu
en tout cas il ya 10 20 drapeau c'est le
champion du monde de la fidh et c'est
lui qui a gagné les normes élimination
de systèmes coupe organisée par la fidh
et à las vegas en septembre octobre
dernier donc qualif man qui ne confirme
pas son titre de champion du monde de la
fidh et c'est un peu comme au cyclisme
le champion du monde cyclisme une gaine
pas le tour de france oui et dernier
finalement piquette qui fait un tournant
plus que moyen finalement qu'elle était
pour un super challenge
piquette n'est pas dernier stéphane
d'année n'est pas la portée des lyonnais
dominateurs en espérant papyrus qui
s'est remis pour l'occasion à jouer aux
échecs c'est le local de l'épreuve pour
ainsi dire il s'agit de l'allemand donc
robert huber qui rappelons le est expert
donc en égyptologie papyrus et diverses
choses il ne serait même plus fort
qu'aux échecs alors qu'il a quand même
un très très bon niveau c'est à dire que
c'est un délaissé le kasparov du papyrus
thé jus dans un transat h avec des
étapes mondiales et les fectivement une
figure pas si mal donc le docteur vient
enfin non pas si malheureux je me
reprends puisqu'il fait deux points sur
neuf
c'est une mauvaise performance pour le
joueur allemand voilà donc sur le
classement je crois qu'on a on a fait le
tour alors tout de suite je crois qu'on
va voir maintenant un clip sympa de
présentation du tournoi
oui alors évidemment la première chose
qu'on va vous montrer c'est des images
des images des images superbes tournoi
donc des très belles images
ce tournoi de dortmund dans une salle de
théâtre c'est très joli donc vous allez
voir donc peut-être top tv
oh
bon
et vous
oh
donc un dernier plan et lois en
diagonale oui tout à fait en diagonale à
l'image de l'émission donc lorsque voilà
ce qu'on peut noter donc sur ces images
deux choses dont on retrouve ce qu'on
retrouve dans ces grands tourments c'est
à dire les échiquier géant qui
permettent au public de suivre les
parties et je crois deuxième point c'est
que par rapport à l'année dernière
puisque on y était pour l'année dernière
aussi pour le premier reportage
d'ailleurs à l'extérieur de diagonale
enfin hors france en tout cas c'était
pas dans le même théâtre c'était pas
dans nos vertes c'était la salle d'à
côté donc il est un peu plus petit mais
effectivement cette année elle était
complètement plein il y avait des gens
debout dans la salle c'est tout à fait
impressionnant il y avait quand même 600
classes dans cette salle
donc c'est beaucoup beaucoup de monde à
c'est un très beau succès les allemands
très friands donc du jeu d'échecs qui
sont venus en masse pour soutenir leurs
joueurs leurs joueurs donc ce n'était
pas aux berruyères puisque le coeur des
allemands mais plutôt pour peter l'écho
ou pour alexander kalichman qui donc
sont plus ou moins on va dire maintenant
des allemands puisque l'un habite en
allemagne et l'autre est sponsorisé par
une firme allemande est un peureux
bergner qui lui vraiment allemand à
wired déficit est d'encourager un joueur
qui ne marche pas bien qu'il n'ya pas
très bien réussi alors toi à nicolas que
quelqu'un ait fait ça te fait de voir
ces images là t'es jamais allé voir un
grand tournoi comme ça alors à
l'étranger n'ont par contre j'ai déjà vu
quelques grands tournois grâce à
diagonale puisque c'était au grand prix
de bordeaux et auprès du sénat donc j'ai
connaît le côté spectacle de sa grâce
grâce à canal web et diaconale quand
même d'accord en est donc là allez tous
les joueurs tous les autres ont conduit
la tuer alors qu'on vient maintenant de
vue oui de vue parce que bon sur les
commentent l'actualité sur sur mon site
c'est vrai que voir les images comme ça
notamment dako pions on a parfois du mal
à faire le du sel quand tu vois une
image statique et puis une image comme
ça qu'ils bougent les joueurs qui m'ont
n'a pas toujours facile de reconnaître
mais j'aurais bien aimé être sur place
quand même alors qu'est ce qu'est ce qui
s'est passé de particulier dans d'autres
ce reportage à leur compte et loire est
ce qu'il ya eu des anecdotes dans le jeu
ou autour du jeu d'inspecter la très
particulière et bien des anecdotes il y
en a eu puisque nous avons croisé sur
place un français nous avons croisé
joseph blatter qui a commencé à nous
commenter tout le tournoi avec un
français plus qu'aléatoire mais c'était
en tout cas très agréable sur vos
anecdotes sur les joueurs bon il y en a
toujours mais elles sont malheureusement
pas racontable donc je vais pas vous les
raconter le son n'est pas ici pour faire
du people
mais effectivement c'est toujours très
très chaud danser dans les couloirs dans
les coulisses de ces grands tournois
d'échecs
donc évidemment la grande particularité
de ce tournoi s'est dit junior
je pense qu'on en a pas forcément assez
parlé puisque quand même c'est vraiment
l'élément qui d'après l'organisateur du
tournoi lui-même a amené tous publics un
peu donné du piment un piment
supplémentaire à ce tournoi
donc en tout cas les commentaires sur
dix juniors refusé à tout va chacun en
mettant son grain de sel à la discussion
et c'était vraiment ce qui a un peu mis
en émulsion ce tournoi de retraite qui a
attiré le public aussi de voir les
joueurs cessé de se battre contre une
machine à priori plus forte
en tout cas vous présentez comme comme
tel dans les différents médias
quand on voit des joueurs comme à nantes
qui font envie
avec les blancs quand une machine comme
ça c'est quand même relativement
surprenant on a bien vu kasparov se
faire battre déjà c'est vrai c'est vrai
ce n'est sur un match il reste vague
presque aussi bon on va pas lancer de
débat ce soir mais peut-être ça sera
l'occasion d'une prochaine émission
mais je crois qu'il ya beaucoup à dire
sur ce match
toujours est il que la machine semble
être réellement très forte oui mais bon
de toute façon au cours du reportage on
va revenir sur les commentaires des
joueurs qui ont tous donné quelques
commentaires sur sur ce fameux deep dit
junior qui est je crois en fait une
extension de l'audit peuvent louer ou
quelque chose comme ça non je crois pas
car ça a été fait par une firme
israélienne ont effectivement langue de
l'autre étaient américains donc ça va
bien sur tu sembles et que c'était même
programme
non c'est pas même premier a eu un autre
lundi blue junior qui a existé
c'était la version lite de deepblue mais
qui tournait pas sur le même processeur
qui avait été mis en place parisienne
mais il ya le dit junior à israélien n'a
pas en a pas de rapport avec 10 points
d'accord en tout cas on va voir tout de
suite mais un joueur qui va parler de
son tournoi c'est vladimir akopian
vice-champion du monde officiel de la
fidl et qui finalement fait un bon
tournoi puisqu'il est 3e ex-aequo et non
qui se hisse au niveau des tout
meilleurs mondiaux
enfin pékin copiant et pas dans l'est
dix meilleurs mondiaux puisqu'il est aux
alentours de la vingtième ou 30e façon
légale oui ça doit tourner à peu près
dans ces eaux là en tout cas nous
l'avons interviewé en phase du tournoi
c'est à dire en plein air puisque il ya
beaucoup d'arbres en allemagne et
copines on était assez prolixe et assez
intéressés par cette interview de
jean-luc chavanon donc un conflit avec
des arbres sur notre news oui on a une
flotte office supplies to none of date
montrent à l'envi la tête ou trop tôt mr
vladimir à compiègne à l'eau alors
justin game vis à vis des merveilles
pourtant panoplie cause de la studio you
you play together in las vegas ce projet
n'est pas très gai
tous ces problèmes
proposition
moi je continue il veut tout le public à
la sauvette
les répondants was there was 9 and the
words i was aussi stand up magnifique
hall du conseil général relax mise au
point et préfère ce taux à 40
on allait le tronçon à 19 heures manson
sockets notre seconde can come back de
patrice machine
notre vrai qu'on montre les graves
difficultés se concentrent play with
their opponents note aux plantes et aux
machines entre elles sont logiques
abattage ici tout est rose est computer
complet y compris chez les seize dates à
une clause position stratégique l'osm et
l'écouté comme futur big problem sommet
bi poin to get what is au maximum de
vous seulement 68 secondes exactement
mais bien play botswana au kef inquiet
voilà ce lundi mais la copine qui
répondait donc h 1 rue chabanais très
prolixe la première fois je crois non
comme on l'avait déjà vu lors de
l'anniversaire de ma fille et je crois
oui m'apparaissant qu'on l'avait déjà
mais aussi
ah non ne l'est pas eu à bastia
malheureusement mais en fait on l'avait
déjà déjà aperçu là bas donc l'admira
copions qui nous dit pas mal de choses
notamment une où donc qu'on
l'interpellait jour sa partie contre
alexander kalichman donc jean-luc
chavanon me poser la question est ce que
ce n'est pas déstabilisant de jouer
contre un joueur qui n'est jamais assis
alors effectivement avec son orgue
kalichman quand ils jouent une partie il
joue son coup et se casse l'équipe se
lève et va d'ailleurs il quitte like it
la salle de jeu et on ne devrait plus
donc effectivement comme il lui a posé
des problèmes dans l'ouverture via des
merengues ont bien été obligé de
réfléchir beaucoup s'est donc retrouvé
tout seul pendant une demi heure
consécutive avec un rien en face de lui
c'est pas non plus la question est-ce
que c'est pas déstabilisant mais non
puisque akopian fait connaître très bien
falli chemin ils se rencontrent en
finale du championnat du monde il a donc
étudié sa façon de jouer et il a dit
c'est son attitude normale pendant une
partie
il se lève toujours donc ça m'a
absolument pas surpris donc pas un
problème qui ont vu des vidéos pour se
préparer
oui il a il a regardé des gonades et il
a donc vu
le alexander rallyman qui n'est jamais
assis et donc suite à ça il a réussi à
surmonter de ce problème
lundi vers un coup bien aussi pessimiste
quant à l'avenir des êtres humains face
aux ordinateurs
alors oui il dit que la machine a sa
propre logique donc que c'est difficile
de prévoir ses coûts donc ça c'est
déstabilisant pour les joueurs humains
maintenant c'était le jour où chronique
avec l'ordinateur qui est notre parti du
jour en commentera tout à l'heure des
crânes dit qu'il l'a proprement ont
pulvérisé donc vous avez tous les deux
vu de la partie c'est un beau diable
la machine a montré ses limites dans
cette partie de saison verra tout à
l'heure donc bon la question de jean-luc
chavanon vient donc tout naturellement
est-ce qu'il faut pas jouer des
positions fermes et contre la machine où
il y avait plein de manoeuvre et ainsi
de suite et c'est donc beaucoup plus
difficile des algorithmes de calcul de
trouver des coûts logique tout à fait et
la réponse a été oui mais c'est très
très difficile d'obtenir une position
ferme et contre l'ordinateur pour
l'instant les programmeurs ont réussi à
trouver des ouvertures ou la machine
arrive à ouvrir le jeu arrive de ne pas
se retrouver dans ces fameuses position
où il ne comprend plus rien et c'est
pour ça que ça devient de plus en plus
difficile de jouer contre un ordinateur
et encore dernière citation de caupian
la machine progresse très très vite et
ça va devenir très très dur pour les
humains de s'en sortir il ya quelques
années pessimiste quoi très pessimiste
tout car enfin il a cité que peut-être
cramique a trouvé le truc il dit samedi
oui alors après je pense qu'on va voir
l'interview de l'expert un nom vladimir
kramnik séduit explique bien plus en
détail à ce qu'il faut faire
alors mais vladimir kramnik tout de
suite ok dzeko nativi intonations de
choses newswire une de plus center of
veut supporter au monde off dortmund and
i'm glad to speak où il veut
je suppose tard vladimir kramnik l on
nous l'a dit mais un sauna will just oui
neveu machine ce terme il y aura une
prochaine et patrice machine and see you
soon to kill int généraux
supplémentaires aux positions de
machines problème de goût d'ailleurs sur
toutes les lacs you choose hynovis qu'à
9 7 heures jusqu'à neuf positions qui
font ces attaques portent à technikart
vos techniques avec michael adams ont
des machines pleurer verrou solide henan
games vient
ça restera nord de sanaa noomane douik
points à me questionner kedro bykov
différentes tactiques sinotte ne sont
autorisés ammann france on manage to
beat street hockey saône à l'extérieur
ce à domicile offre aux consommateurs
qu'aux formes concernées man is it ce
rendez-vous fantastique match où le
bénin de vis à vis peter ring game
actually hockey fin que voilà venir
beaucoup de choses intéressantes je
crois que tout ce que dit manière est
très intéressant il a donné gâtés
qui lui pend c'est juste une bonne
nicolas pour battre l'ordinateur
effectivement il ya des choses qui m'ont
marqué la première c'est qu'il faut
essayer de garder la position ferme et
le plus longtemps possible et
aujourd'hui c'est très très difficile
d'après ce que dit krainik d'arriver à
ce type de position la machine
aujourd'hui c'est ouvrir une position et
je crois qu'il faut être très
intelligent dans les premiers coups de
la partie exact ex pour rêver à ce temps
effectivement bloquées et puisqu'il a
dit je crois très important c'est ce
qu'il faut garder en tête contre un
ordinateur
s'il faut jouer contre le roi et ça
c'est quelque chose qui c'est la
première fois que j'entends ça
j'ai toujours d'être dans la position
ferme et me dit avoir une position ferme
et est une attaque contre les attaques
contre leurs ouailles à ce moment-là
l'ordinateur ne comprend rien et on en
on verra tout à l'heure on a un peu le
temps que c'est effectivement la
technique qu'il a utilisé tous contre
boillon si les deux défaites de deep
juniors il ya perdu quand il s'est fait
attaquer par pickett et par cramique les
deux positions fermes et loïc attaqué
droit il se fait complètement démonté
tout simplement
et comment est-ce que trawick a trouvé
ça eh bien il s'est préparé tout
simplement il ya des premières clés pour
ton bac l'ordinateur c'est bien se
préparer
c'est bien se préparer c'est à dire
comme pourtant s'apprête à jouer contre
un joueur qu'on ne connaît pas on
regarde les parties qu'il a jouées sur
l'ordinateur
là comme il n'y a pas de tâche et sur
les parties de deep
juniors y a pas de partie sur les
archives 2e junior il a donc il s'est
donc entraîné 8 mai va jouer contre dix
plaignants puisque c'est importe qui
commercialisé et il a essayé tous
différents types de cet homme comme il
dit pour trouver finalement ce truc avec
la pression ferme et il attaque sur le
roi et dernière chose qu'il a dite très
importante c'est que c'était important
d'avoir les blancs c'est beaucoup plus
facile d'avoir les petits ont fermé avec
attaque sur le roi quand on a les blancs
que quand on allait voir tout simplement
alors il ya un an un autre point qui m'a
particulièrement marqué c'est cramé
caddie et les échecs sont aux jo x games
en jeu manu lent oui à l'époque
in fact il a dit en fait à l'aube des
sourds de son match avec kasparov
ouais c'est déjà la peur pour lui non
mais on peut faire confiance à la
demi-heure il va se préparer avec des
très bons des très bons joueurs c'est ce
qui nous a amenés ici c'était son
dernier rendez vous officiel avant le
match entre 4,40 et maintenant il se
prépare mentalement il est déjà deeply
d'adam widadi des grecs bien dans le
match et gagner d'ailleurs que c'était
son dernier tournoi avant le match quand
caspar enfin maintenant se préparer à
fond à fond les manettes il va
s'entraîner avec des amis donc prenons
des gens qui ne connaît pas kasparov ou
qui bat kasparov et on va pas beaucoup
compte en tout cas il va prendre en
chercher je crois que cramique a été
second temps de kasparov tu longtemps où
ils ont travaillé ensemble ils sont deux
jours tu as très proche il me semble non
oui ça me casse pas mais je crois qu'il
a été
un petit peu d'écoles de kasparov a
pendant quelques années que l'os et
spirituelle c1 est aussitôt
voilà en tout cas très intéressante
interview cramique il a dit beaucoup de
choses il a parlé des hommes enfin un
moment donné du tournoi puisqu'il dit on
arrête de parler des machines ou par le
nez désormais il a parlé commenté la
technique un peu l'ordinateur notamment
la technique et le contrôle de
l'ordinateur jeu très très bien et final
tout le monde est d'accord pour dire ça
puisque avec les systèmes de hashtable
alors interprété comme vous le voulez en
tout cas il ya des sites qui va toutes
les positions en mémoire et donc qui
fait que l'ordinateur commence à avoir
très très loin augmenter énormément sa
puissance de calcul en finale en tout
cas on est transposée sur ea maintenant
elle a acheté le permet en fait un
ordinateur député de calculer deux fois
la même position et donc en finale
souvent on se retrouve dans le même type
de position donc ça permet des lags et
énormément et donc d'aller très très
profondément dans l'analyse s'est
effectivement donc un point clé pour les
ordinateurs aujourd'hui en finale
alors maintenant le second du tournoi en
fin de second degré puisqu'il est
ex-aequo avec rami qu'au nombre de
points mais il ya eu un masque de
départage qui donnait l'avantagé à
kramnik mais sur le tournoi lui-même y
sont ex-aequo c'est le numéro ancien
numéro 2 mondial est maintenant numéro 3
parce que chronique est passé devant
c'est l'indien viswanathan anand qu'on a
eu déjà plusieurs fois dandy bonal cette
fois à nantes spécial dortmund diagonale
tv internationales chez news oui on veut
super tout le monde dortmund anaem de
rigolade tout interview mr vichy ah non
elle avait chez sotoudeh ou win the
event match games mike adams my world
tout le monde s'est remis à battre is
game le fantastique actualisé fusent
tout le gaz carbonique ce match peut
être administré aux qu'est ce au juste à
tous picotte adventures you want me
match games
le chef mécano somme somme not so fine
playback boumsong masseur canine prouve
by using computer avec le vih et hop les
catégories de chance avec casino qui
peuplaient internet
probably the people loin des plateaux de
manson internet veilleuse computer to et
2 to not to do mistakes
donc viser à l'internât interviewé par
jules chabanon ils ont parlé de la donne
cette chance à la fin oui principalement
évidemment au début de l'interview que
ces annonces qui commandent sa partie où
il a battu michael adams il a réussi à
battre le fameux gambie marshall
employés par michael adams régulièrement
et la deuxième partie de l'interview
c'est ce que nous avions très tard et
que jean-luc il fallait lui parler
d'advanced chef puisque c'est sa grosse
spécialité à notre ami riche manhattan
chelsea et de l'échec assistée par
ordinateur on s'en sort par m
dortmund fin du politique d'union est là
l'informatique pour une place de plus en
plus important pour l'anc pour des
raisons économiques
ça c'est une des raisons est
effectivement pour des raisons
médiatiques puisque c'est vrai que
l'ordinateur contre l'esprit humain
c'est quand même un très beau une très
belle affiche donc attendre seule pièce
ordinateur hulin contre l'ordinateur
plus humain et allant de gagner toutes
les compétitions qu'il joue il avait
notamment pulvérisé karpov qui n'avaient
pas absolument pas su s'en sortir avec
l'ordinateur qui avait réfléchi des
heures cette heure française ne fait pas
de sa génération
voilà exactement alors que la norme lui
arrive à initialiser l'ordinateur avec
des raccourcis clavier très très vite
la très vite ils configurent tout en
quelques secondes donc on ressent le
spécialiste et il a cette année encore
battu shirov en échec-avant c'est assez
facilement alors la question c'est
est-ce que ça peut créer des
spécialistes est ce que certains joueurs
qui arriveront à s'harmoniser avec
l'ordinateur vont bouleverser la rade
hier la hiérarchie mondiale s'est elle a
par exemple à ce que stéphane laborde du
street peut battre kasparov fritz voilà
la question de de jean-luc chavanon part
je dis tout de suite c'est peu probable
c'est peu probable où il faut une très
forte version en tout cas apparemment la
norme ne veux pas trop me mouiller là
dessus
vu tout est possible excitant donc c'est
parce qu'ils disent très intéressant sur
comment il faut jouer avec l'ordinateur
il dit faut faire il faut savoir
abandonner s'il faut croire l'ordinateur
sur ce que l'ordinateur propose comme
coup ou pas en fait vous vous réfléchir
par soi même il ya des moments où il
faut mais prendre la bonne décision
oui j'ai vont pas la vie de la machine
j'ai l'impression qu'un mandat prix en
fait le comment dire la machine par le
bon bout
c'est à dire qu'il sait de la machine
bonbons par le bon côté c'est de la
machine pour vérifier ses calculs il
cède pas de la machine comme force de
proposition
il cède pour vérifier ces combinaisons
et je pense que c'est là le bon la bonne
logique la bonne façon de procéder avec
ce type de compétition où il a mentionné
un des deux travers principaux dont il
ya deux possibilités soit on croit
toujours l'ordinateur à ce moment là
c'est pas bon soit justement on sait en
fait ça c'est se laisser endormir par
les calculs de la machine c'était de
faire l'esprit enfin arrêter de faire
fonctionner son esprit arrêté de
réfléchir tout simplement et l'autre
travers ces deux justement d'oublier la
machine comme l'a fait karpov
mais c'est ça le gros truc c'est ça
c'est qu'il faut savoir qu on croire ou
ne pas croire la machine je pense que et
il l'a bien dit et on l'a compris tout à
fait alors on va voir maintenant on va y
venir puisque
tu parlais tout à l'heure de l'interview
de la machine est bien à l'interview
d'audit junior lui-même diffusion en
personne d'alain fondre question alors
vous allez voir c'est jean luc châtel
d'interviewer voilà force interviews de
la machine par gilles achats là non
tonio sometimes the view à ce programme
one of the top games ce programme en
deux ans qui est dauphine cowitz
personnes sexually infinty pas sans le
savoir est un peu confus et aussi mme
stoecklé well in technique elle
positionne en dessous une tactique sauf
qu'au reste de la mécanique comique une
positionne à la ''place au possible to
predict services à disposition
fritz difficulté mais que johnny planes
and because he believes that women and
family games computer and a happy to
play such as the uk les boycotts
computers et easybag l'équation sera
amené à vous a dit houle ou aux attentes
visionnez un doublé championnat de
hockey
voilà donc en fait vous êtes bien
compris c'était le programmeur
évidemment de la machine et non pas la
machine est le même
c'était donc monsieur boucher de ski une
israélienne qui programmeurs de cette
machine les programmeurs et directeur du
managing de kasparov 15 points comme qui
retransmettait les parties en direct
donc double casquette pour ce monsieur
chaibou chinsky qui a répondu à toutes
les questions avec brio et
très clairement très clairement voilà
donc il a analysé notamment l'aspect
intérêt de mettre la machine dans le
tournoi en disant que c'était un atout
pour intéresser les gens autour mois
puisque clairement
need par rapport au web site qui
retransmettent le tournoi ou par rapport
au public en général c'est un atout
supplémentaire pour que les gens
s'intéressent aux échecs oui en fait il
est en train d'expliquer que peu à peu
les grands maintenant en plus le choix
entre jouer ou ne pas jouer contre
l'ordinateur puisque on a déjà vu des
grands maîtres s'abstenir dire non moi
pas de machine je ne veux pas jouer
maintenant on n'aura plus le choix
puisqu'en fait le public réclame du sang
de tous ville veut des circuits imprimés
contre de la chair fraîche
après avoir goûté à ça il commence à y
être habitué maintenant ils en
redemandent
donc de toutes façons ne pourra plus se
défiler quand la machine arrivera donc
c'est une vraie boucherie
ça va tourner à la boucherie qu'est ce
qu'on peut dire il a aussi dit une
déclaration je dirais philosophique du
genre l'histoire n'arrête pas la
technologie bon c'est vrai que quand on
regarde au fil des années bon il ya une
dizaine d'années une quinzaine d'années
la force des programmes la force des
programmes aujourd'hui elle s'accroît de
manière assez exponentielle donc il est
vrai que si la courbe continue telle
qu'elle est aujourd'hui
kasparov aura beaucoup de fils y assure
dans quelques années peut-être on pourra
imaginer qu'un jour au champion du monde
se fasse entre deux machines et oui
voyez on peut l'imaginer mais enfin là
ça perdra un peu du ca perdre un petit
peu d'intérêt quand même dans ce qui est
bien c'est comme se fait virer doter
cette dualité oui côté ce qui est bien
c'est si l'ordinateur continue à
accroître sa force
on aura sans doute quelque chose à
prendre aussi de l'ordinateur pour nous
apprendre des choses très intéressantes
dans certaines certains compartiments du
jeu
il ya quelque chose qui m'a marqué dans
cette interview c'est l'aspect
stratégique
aujourd'hui la machine joue
stratégiquement très très bien mais il a
souligné notamment avec la partie contre
adam ça où
il a souligné l' expertise d'adams type
de position stratégique la machine a su
faire face oui mais est ce que c'est
c'est la question qui est posée aux 6 et
on a l'impression qu'elle joue bien
stratégiquement mais peut-être parce
qu'elle a tout calculé les coûts qu'il
fallait pas jouer alors il va trouver le
coup je crois correct je crois pas je
pense qu'aujourd'hui parce que quand
même le canton à la partie de cramique
une piquette contre la machine on se dit
non pas elle joue pas bien
stratégiquement par contre oui peut être
oui parce qu'effectivement il ya un
effet d'horizon mais aujourd'hui je
pense qu'elle quand même très très bonne
intelligence qui est programmé à
l'intérieur de deux de ses machines
je pense que la machine va devenir
vraiment très très très très coriace
dans les machines dans les années à
venir même si l'homme sera toujours
trouver un chemin dans la victoire
voyez alors donc parce que je vous
arrête parce qu'en fait vous êtes parti
un petit peu vous avez donc pas fait la
différence entre stratégique et
technique
non mais ce n'est pas du tout la même
chose la stratégie c'est les plans les
manoeuvres et la technique c'est la
précision en finale c'est pas du tout
pareil
donc effectivement la machine sur le
plan technique je voudrais bien de son
plan stratégique encore des choses à
apprendre
là par contre on appris une chose très
intéressante dans cette interview c'est
que chronique a bluffé la machine
puisque il a déclaré donc en fait le
programme art de machines a déclaré
kramnik avait dit que la machine calcule
mal alors donc voilà alors qu'en fait
kramnik nous avait redit que le gros
défaut de la machine séquence au roi
s'est attaqué à une position ferme et ce
qui est tout sauf du calcul les projets
monsieur potchinsky il va analyser les
parties c'est comme comme un vrai joueur
en fait on nous allons analyser les
parties de juniors voir où est ce qu'ils
jouent bien voici je dois bien
identifier les problèmes et en tout cas
ce qu'il dit c'est que maintenant déjà
si on achète son programme donc sans
surprise on a un des meilleurs joueurs
du monde à la maison ce qui paraît il au
risque aussi on finira par ça mais elle
risque aussi j'ai pensé en venant c'est
parti contre l'ordinateur de pouvoir
répéter une partie jouée puisqu'a priori
si on rejoue la même position que la
machine se met à réfléchir on n'a plus
le choix aléatoire de son ouverture des
ondes possible si on retrouve la même
position a priori et si on joue les
mêmes cool va jouer les mêmes réponses
donc on peut aussi se demander si on
trouve une solution pour la battre les
joueurs auraient tendance à répéter
wells essayer de répéter les partis qui
ont été faites qu'on ait des algorithmes
qui sont aujourd'hui très très très
complexe et qui permettent à prendre par
rapport à une position donnée ne pas
rejouer deux fois les mêmes erreurs et
donc des systèmes cognitifs qui
permettent donc de dub et d'éviter de
reproduire les même bourde d'une partie
sur une autre et peut-être de ne pas
produire plus tôt ne pas les choisir
voilà maintenant on va voir l'interview
de youppi 4 le hollandais a dit m
wendel portant caution de bâtir carry
your play mini ministres ont tout le
monde s'est tu vises mountain state of
so canio tale of what you need to to
which to reach tout tout tout mecs on
progresse à vis à vis à vis à vis d'un
piano probably next world championship
population what you do not just want you
she's got the level of junior
et si sa mort est une piquette qui
expliquait que c'est pas faut toujours
facile de comprendre comment progresser
et pourquoi parfois il faisait de bons
tournois et parfois des plus mauvais oui
c'est la question qu'on lui avait
concocté avec jean-luc c'est-à-dire il
ya une piquette a réussi à battre
kasparov c'est un des rares joueurs qui
a battu kasparov en semi rapides et sur
internet mon sens une grande moitié du
nouveau grand prix tu as part of alors
pourquoi est ce qu'ils arrivent pas à
réitérer cet exploit souvent eh bien
tout simplement d'après dire une
piquette c'est qu'il n'arrive pas à
contrôler sa forme il ne sait pas il ne
sait pas ce qui se passera de chimie de
son corps en tout cas pourquoi est-ce
que certains tournois il est et d'autres
n'avaient pas les limites
oui exactement est en tout cas il ne
ne comprends pas ils n'arrivent pas en
tout cas être au meilleur niveau tout le
temps et autres problèmes qui d'assez
qu'ils n'arrivent pas toujours à saisir
sa chance suffisamment ils n'arrivent
pas donc à marquer le point quand le
quand il n'y a plus qu'à quatre buts
voilà notre quête qui va se préparer à
partir de septembre donc images ou
encore du tournoi juillet août a pas de
septembre et octobre pour les olympiades
et le championnat du monde de new delhi
oui et teyran il a fait une déclaration
qu'on verse elle aussi l'a dit que fritz
se joue mieux que junior voilà voilà
les compagnies british qui avait joué le
jeu plein de hollande oui j'aurais pu
inclure une piquette et donc aux landais
on va passer maintenant au numéro un
anglais est maintenant numéro cinq
mondial il a progressé c'est michael
adams non ce sera peut-être alexander
frei von ah oui pardon alexandra
lippmann surtout du groupe
ce serait dommage ballard y est tout à
fait la connectivité internationale chez
news world trade center
alexander kalichman alexander non vers
le négatif batt o'keeffe ami ok my
french défense vote ce mardi 20 octobre
à hua hin maintenant laghmani
douloureuse de la veste au championnat
next world championship une machine
machine mois en mois
dans la victoire
la position est cof de g league est une
preuve du baril contre dans les machines
de sauviat entre new in germany de your
song était une mutation une goutte times
and germany bat fine et très peu de m
ok ok go
alexander kalichman qui regrette d'avoir
raté vishy anand dans la première ronde
c'est un bruit de lavaur a t il été
gagnant il a perdu ensuite c'est un peu
comme un dynamisme et enchaîne avec un
nul mais le tournoi n'a de toute façon
pas fonctionné alors parcours sujet
épineux
oui si j'ai pu mais rigolo parce que
donc l'actionnaire canyon par rapport au
championnat du monde d'échecs lundi que
bon messi très bien si ça a lieu si
sérieux dans ces endroits exotiques
exotiques et dit que la fidea le don de
surprendre tout le monde y compris les
joueurs d'échecs ce qui est tout à fait
pas mal pour die peu junior il dit qu'il
a des pointes de structure et que
travnik l'a bien démontré
mais qu'on arrive dans la nouvelle ère
du jeu d'échec c'est à dire qu'en fait
les ordinateurs effectivement maintenant
faut vraiment partie du paysage et s'y
tient en tout cas les fans très
sympathique c'est une interview qui
n'obtient qui s'est même excusé dans le
monde est d'avoir perdu le fil de ce
qu'ils voulaient dire enfin est tout à
fait vrai très sympa très sympa et on va
passer à un autre joueur très sympas ils
sont tous très sympa toute façon c'est
michael adams donc cette fois le
véritable numéro un anglais et numéro
cinq mondial actuel alors michael est en
train d'arriver
voilà temps opérable qu'à lyon bon là il
s'était qualifié de sage ils font le
caler alors vous allez voir cette
interview qu'elle adapte une question
très très surprenante de jean-luc
chavanon qui lui a posé c'est en fait
c'est ce qu'on appelle la cagade la case
la gamme de michael adams
si on
cela bientôt près la cagade non enfin
alors on va commenter ou après commenter
l'interview pour ceux qui veulent le
voir en anglais ils verront après
jean-luc chavanon demandant un michael
adams
alors ça te fait quoi d'être le plus
fort joueurs de l'ouest de tous les
temps et jean-luc avait tout simplement
oublié bobby fischer effectivement qu'il
n'était pas forcément le moindre
voilà donc ça c'était la fameuse cagade
et michael adams toujours très
flegmatique films dits très tranquille
qui garde son sang froid
en regardant cette news oui peut plus
s'entêter à dams la visite en birmanie
quand new zealand visciano one of early
works et black to know because you soon
the next one man show ici compétition
casino a very modeste résulte un
week-end considère votre i wanna be veut
historique
voilà très sympathique mcadams est en
pleine forme
mais comme toujours nous dit que le
niveau que je vais en général augmenté
effectivement c'est une réalité sinon
sur son tournoi il est effectivement
assez satisfait de sa prestation ici et
enfin on va en trouver maintenant en
dernier peter l'écho le hongrois qui
fait un très bon tournant puisqu'il est
3e ex-aequo il était gagnant l'année
dernière donc c'est un peu moins bien
mais bon il est toujours là il un super
forme
il a battu caspar enfin il a pas de
suites et spa enfin en forêt où ils ont
débattu sur une superbe défense
renouvelle et il est là en direct sur
canal peter l'écho l'écho match et news
oui on va plus entre supertramp mountain
am very happy to speak with mr petrikov
en gagnant le championnat grec to ask
you some [ __ ] battu calais puis
saute à millau sensation thing et mike
bryan mais non à la quenouille assure
fighting for first person 2
une nouvelle jolie de fdr sans problème
par exemple les stades et michael
costigan sociales et économiques sociaux
et ce goût de la fing because you finish
with many times white probably tout un
voyou utilise pourtant things to play in
germany trade invest in your own you
can't read our love go betweens de la
mani mani spectateurs sein des très loin
que rom atmosphère bat offre aux
aéronefs sans obligation fort exemple
faut de sponsoring est aux commentateurs
de game mag info de public
notre chance aux restos du coeur
le stade est à espoo que with mr pink
funhouse pas que bertrand gadenne chef
vicieux ou have to be good boy the
olympians un after work chairmanship
ayew récupère d'ailleurs absente futuna
tout
to find some kind of something stoppeur
before he is to be xv rendez vous live
cause afp période bat son plein de l'as
roma la story line up so why there are
preparing à l'autonomie media gateway
goodrich fine maille pelé garrincha
think and paper martin alarie les nice
practice so you may be one of the free
players who did not plug and the machine
bah vi résultat vos machines gilbert
impressive non identiques et s'élèvent à
la crise la chine est un des big data
that it right of most of the player ok
cupid la grèce et voilà donc ça passe
interview de peter l'écho c'est fini je
crois je vous remercie et puis tous y
compris à lui qu'est revenue la semaine
prochaine pour la suite des événements
avec un reportage sur bienne voit la
suisse
exactement
oh